- [Voiceover] So right over here, we have
one rational expression being subtracted
from another rational expression.
I encourage you to pause the video
and see what this would result in.
So actually do the subtraction.
Alright, let's do this together.
And if we're subtracting
two rational expressions,
we'd like to have them
have the same denominator.
And they clearly don't
have the same denominator
and so we need to find
a common denominator.
And a common denominator is one that
is going to be divisible
by either of these
and then we can multiply them by
an appropriate expression or number
so that it becomes the common denominator.
So the easiest common denominator
I can think of especially
because these factors,
these two expressions have no factors
in common, would just be their product.
So this is going to be equal to,
so we could just multiply these two.
So this is going to be, so let me do,
let me do this one right
over here, in magenta.
So this is going to be equal to
the common denominator.
If I say, if I want to just multiply
those two denominators.
For this one, I'll have my 8x plus seven
and now I'm going to
multiply by 3x plus one.
Multiplying it by the other denominator
and I had negative 5x in the numerator
but if I'm going to
multiply the denominator
by 3x plus one and I don't want to change
the value of the expression, we'll have
to multiply the numerator
by 3x plus one, as well.
Notice, 3x plus one divided
by 3x plus one is just one
and you'll be left with
what we started with.
And from that, we are going
to subtract all of this.
Now there's a couple of ways you
can think of this subtraction.
I could just write a
minus sign right over here
and do the same thing that I
just did for the first term.
Or another way to think about it
and actually for this particular case,
I like thinking about it better this way,
is to just add the negative of this.
So if I just multiply negative
one times this expression,
I'd get negative 6x
third over 3x plus one.
If I had more terms up
here, in the numerator,
I would have to be careful to distribute
that negative sign, but
here, I only have one term.
So I just made a negative and so I can say
this is going to be plus
and, let me do this,
in a new color, do this in green.
Our common denominator,
we already established,
is the product of our two denominators
so it is going to be 8x plus
seven times 3x plus one.
Now if we multiply the denominator here
was 3x plus one, we're
multiplying it by 8x plus seven.
So that mean's we have to multiply
the numerator by 8x plus seven as well.
8x plus seven times negative
6x to the third power.
Notice, 8x plus seven divided
by 8x plus seven is one.
If you were to do that, you would get back
to your original
expression right over here,
the negative 6x to the
third over 3x plus one.
And now, we're ready to add.
This is all going to be equal to,
I'll write the denominator in white.
So we have our common denominator,
8x plus seven times 3x plus one.
Now, in the magenta, I would want
to distribute the negative 5x,
so negative 5x times positive
3x is negative 15x squared.
And then, negative 5x
times one is minus 5x.
And then, in the green, I would have,
let's see, I'll distribute the negative 6x
to the third power, so
negative 6x to the third
times positive 8x is going to be,
negative 48x to the fourth power.
And then negative 6x to the third
times positive seven is
going to be negative 42,
negative 42x to the third.
And I think I'm done
because there's no more,
there's, you know, I only
have one fourth-degree term,
one third-degree term,
one second-degree term,
one first-degree term, and that's it.
There's no more simplification here.
Some of you might want to just write it
in descending degree order,
so you could write it
as negative 48x to the fourth minus 42x
to the third minus 15x squared minus 5x.
All of that over 8x plus
seven times 3x plus one.
But either way, we are all done.
I mean, it looks like up here, yeah,
there's no, nothing to factor out.
These two are divisible by five.
These are divisible by six but even
if I were to factor that
out, nothing over here,
down here, no five or six to factor out.
Yeah, so it looks like we are all done.